earlier in our mathematical adventures
we had expanded things like x
plus y
times x minus y just as a bit of review
this is going to be equal to x times x
which is x squared plus x times negative
y which is negative x y
plus y times x which is plus
x y and then minus y times y or you
could say y times a negative y so it's
going to be minus y squared
negative xy positive xy so this is just
going to simplify to x squared
minus y squared and this is all review
we covered it and when we thought about
factoring things that are differences of
squares we thought about this when we
were first learning to multiply
binomials
and what we're going to do now is
essentially just do the same thing but
do it with slightly more complicated
expressions and so another way of
expressing what we just did is we could
also write something like a plus b
times a minus b is going to be equal to
what well it's going to be equal to a
squared
minus b squared the only difference
between what i did up here and what i
did over here is instead of an x i wrote
an a instead of a y i wrote a b
so given that let's see if we can expand
and then combine like terms for
if i'm multiplying these two expressions
say i'm multiplying three plus five x to
the fourth
times three minus five x to the fourth
pause this video and see if you can work
this out
all right well there's two ways to
approach it you could just approach it
exactly the way that i approached it up
here but we already know that when we
have this pattern where we have
something plus something times that same
original something minus the other
something well that's going to be of the
form of this thing squared minus this
thing squared and remember the only
reason why i'm applying that is i have a
3 right over here and here so the 3 is
playing the role of the a so let me
write that down that is our a
and then the role of the b is being
played by 5x to the fourth
so that is our b right over there so
this is going to be equal to a squared
minus b squared but our a is 3 so it's
going to be equal to 3 squared
minus and then our b is 5x to the 4th
minus 5x to the 4th squared now what
does all of this simplify to
well this is going to be equal to 3
squared is 9 and then minus 5x to the
fourth squared let's see 5 squared is 25
and then x to the 4th squared well that
is just going to be x to the 4 times x
to the fourth which is just x to the 8th
another way to think about it our
exponent properties we are this is the
same thing as 5 squared times x to the
4th squared if i raise them to an
exponent and then raise that to another
exponent i multiply the exponents and
there you have it
let's do another example
let's say that i were to ask you
what is three
y squared plus two y to the fifth
times three y squared minus 2y to the
fifth pause this video and see if you
can work that out
well we're going to do it the same way
you can of course always just try to
expand it out the way we did originally
but we could recognize here that hey i
have an a plus a b times the a minus a b
so that's going to be equal to our a
squared so what's 3y squared well that's
going to be 9 y to the 4th
minus our b squared well what's 2y to
the fifth squared
well 2 squared is 4 and y to the 5th
squared is y to the 5 times 2 y to the
10th power and there's no further
simplification that i could do here i
can't combine any like terms and so we
are done here as well